kyle in san antonio texas
yeehaw kyle what's up hey dr d how's it
going man good to talk to you
outstanding good to talk to you too man
what's up
so um calling about a relationship with
my two sisters two older sisters that
has gone
stale and just been scarred up pretty
bad
from uh from when my father passed away
and uh
just trying to find some help in how we
can reconcile that what i can do to
get back to where we were before then or
or just
something going forward that could be a
little a little better
man i hate that for you when's your
when's your dad pass away
that was in 2018 so uh
september 2018 so it's been enough time
now where i'm kind of the person that
says time heals all wounds but
um there's still some scars there that
we're trying to recover from i know me
individually and i know we all have
our own so i'm trying to i guess give
them some grace and
and understand that may be different for
everyone but um
just hasn't been where it used to be i
just looked for some help in that area
yeah so tell me what happened
start with your dad was it a sudden
passing
so yes my dad was 67 it was a sudden
passing
um and he was in a different state so
literally i remember walking my young
daughters around the neighborhood
and then getting home to a text of hey
have you heard it from dad and uh
hadn't and uh man i'm so sorry and then
just all just kind of
happened really fast and so we go out
there and
and resolve um you know all that
and uh really the the issue i guess the
thing with my sisters has
had to came down to the uh kind of the
estate
the the fact that i was appointed as the
executor was oh man um
was this i guess not really a surprise
because all three of us
we had this amazing relationship before
like um
just amazing sibling relationship to the
point where i heard about other
siblings having difficulties and i'm
like how could that be possible we have
this amazing relationship
i couldn't imagine not having a great
relationship with my sisters yeah
and um and there's also kind of a
curveball in here with
my mom who separated my dad about 15
years before then but never actually
divorced
so um we were trying to manage
relationships with each one of them
individually and i would say we all had
a
a better relationship with my dad we all
kind of that was our home that we grew
up in
and my dad and my mom we kind of
observed them
go through that kind of rocky marriage
um and kind of
a marriage that i think we all agree
that we did not want to have
in our lives but she still has a claim
to some of that estate huh
so yes um you know just trying to
manage the whole death was already so
much and then there was just this like
legal side of everything that was
overwhelming so um
yeah it's kind of crazy i remember like
i'm like 27 28 years old and
i'm just having kids i'm asking my dad
if he has a will and he had just made
his will like i think a year before
passing which is kind of ironic
yeah um and then and then it's kind of
one of those back of the napkin wills
and um and again i didn't think i think
he could have appointed anyone he chose
me i don't think there was any
reason between his three kids i happen
to be the youngest
um but i don't know so my guess kyle
honestly and that's
it's noble of you to try to pass that
off like he just you know picked a
random person but
um my guess is he picked you
intentionally whether he thought you
were the most mature he might have just
picked you because you were the male
and that sounds like a very texan thing
to do
and he might have done it um
trying to protect your sisters and their
pretty little heads from having to worry
about anything
and however misguided that might have
been right so it may have been noble it
may have been
um it may have been any number of
reasons why
but just to think he just randomly
picked you is dismissive of you right
um to own it he he picked you so walk me
through what's what's happened with your
sisters
why and why are they frustrated with you
why is your relationship fractured since
he passed
so the whole um the estate was not
anything special it was you know just
obviously a pretty normal middle class
situation
and then uh but the weird thing with my
mom is there was one thing that my mom
presented to me
it was signed by my dad that said uh hey
uh
because they had split the title of the
house or whatnot it said hey
you agreed to have me be the selling
agent on the house
my mom just i guess wanted to have that
sure there's some money in there i don't
know
i don't know i don't know it was their
agreement and he had signed it they had
both signed it
so when she presented that to me i felt
obligated to honor that
just like the few other things that he
signed that you know
to me it's kind of a cut and dry like
that's not an issue so right
so i i had to tell my sisters that hey
mom's gonna
sell the house and um there's just so
much
bad blood there that they're like how
dare you is how could you not honor his
spirit how could you let that happen
he would never let her step foot in that
house blah blah blah
and so i was um i was really kind of
desperate and torn because i understand
where they're coming from but i also
kind of understand he's
in my heart like i felt that he was the
kind of guy that knew what he was doing
when he signed that and so
um so just breaking the news to them
they
there was just so many words that were
said that i can never forget
along the lines of um never going to
talk to you ever again i'm going to
we're going to get our own lawyer and
sue you um you know you're just
disgracing his
spirit and and your you know you're
taking sides and uh
and just this is a really it just caught
me so much off guard where i was just
like hey guys
he signed this thing you know you have
to understand where i'm coming from and
i was kind of just desperate for them to
understand this is so hard already like
let's not make this harder
so there's just a lot of bad words uh
exchanged
and so now i'm trying to um now we've
kind of moved on we live in separate
cities but we just don't have a
relationship
anywhere where it was before and so i'm
trying to understand is that me do i
need to reach out to them it's just not
where it is
so here's here's here's a couple of
things to to think through here okay
number one think of grief like a
um you know those big giant rubber
bouncy balls
that you can just smash on the ground
and they'll just fly around
everywhere ping pong on off of
everything think of grief that way
and you have three siblings all of you
opened up a pantry door and just smashed
that ball in there
and it would bounce in different
trajectories for everybody
and so if your sister said some things
that were really hurtful
if they were really frustrating if they
were really just
cut you in your soul after the sudden
passing of your dad
i'm gonna tell you a hundred percent
those things hurt
they are like knives in your soul
especially when you're trying to grieve
and do the right
thing but i want you to forgive them and
set that stuff down
they were hurting in a way that they
probably had no
no way to comprehend or wrap their head
around it their disdain for your mom who
bailed on their dad
those things get magnified when somebody
suddenly passes
then we start looking for faults and
blame and who hurt who and all that kind
of stuff and when someone just drops
dead of a heart attack
it's hard because there's there's not
much to blame there right so then
a shadowy figure emerges whose mom who
is mean to our dad and
um then it just gets messy from there at
the end of the day
those things hurt but the more you carry
them around they're not hurting your
sisters anymore they're just hurting you
and so i would set him down and
if you haven't my hope is you have spent
some time alone
not in the math problem of dealing with
an estate but
in the grief part of losing your old man
i hope you've spent some time actually
grieving that because that sucks
that really you know i think i have um
not yeah
and i've talked about it with my wife
and
i think it's just distracted by other
things and
i've been tried to seek out help here
and there
definitely not enough but i'm sitting
here like talking to my wife and trying
to be honest with myself and i just
don't feel like i've faced that yet but
i also feel like it's because i have
other scars that i'm trying to dealing
with that either distract me i don't
know if
i wanted to or not but yeah i'm um so
you're gonna
not disagree with you you're gonna i
think it starts
tonight or tomorrow when you're in a
space and it might you might need to
tell your wife hey i need you to take
the kids tonight
um and i want you to
best you can write your dad a long long
letter about the things you remember
remember about him the things you loved
about
the dude i wish you hadn't written your
will on a napkin be mad at him
um be frustrated about his marriage
and let him know why didn't you just
divorce mom that would have made this a
lot easier
and then i want you to spend some time
writing about
the man you are the dad you're gonna be
the dad you are the husband you are and
let him know who you're becoming
okay and i want you to be honest in this
letter and be open in this letter and if
you say ugly mean things and things spew
out of you that you didn't know were
there that's okay that's not a
that's not a black mark on his memory um
it's that's honoring him with your
authenticity and
um if you remember things that bring you
joy and make you laugh cry that's
awesome too
um and then giving yourself a place that
you're gonna head to next where are you
living what's the legacy that your old
man is passing through you that you'll
pass on to your kids
it's important to write that stuff down
and this won't be a one-time thing
right this won't be a oh we're all good
now right
right you may want to get some guys
together from your local community from
your local church and
talk about dads do something like that
be the guy that goes first be vulnerable
right
the second thing here is this is
reaching out to your sisters
um
at some point you're gonna have to if
you want to preserve a relationship
which is what it sounds like you want to
it's letting them know that you love
them you're here
and um they may never come around and
say they were sorry
they may hold what happened forever
that's theirs to hold not yours
right um and maybe it's time that you
send them a handwritten letter to their
home
and say i miss my sisters and say dad's
um dad's sudden death caught us all off
guard
his arrangements with mom were weird and
were not
in the best interest of those who were
his survivors right weren't in the best
interest of his kids
but they were what they were i love you
guys and
i'm ready to have what we had and
all you can do at this point kyle is go
first
is to risk to be uh put the relationship
out there and they may reject you
brother
they may say screw you we're still not
over it i don't think they will
i think you're a guy of a solid with a
solid heart and you're a great human
being so i don't think they're going to
but they might
and that's what this whole thing is
about is about risk right it's like
leaning forward
and heading into that here's a couple of
things
number one if you're listening to this
don't do a napkin on a will on a napkin
if you are separated from somebody and
it's not coming back
go through the legal processes and
if you are not living with somebody for
15 years make it official and go
and get your divorce get the stuff
illegally separated
so your poor kids don't lose their
relationship dealing with your mess
it's childish and it's ridiculous
it's just dumb okay um
you can make a will we have a will here
through
um with relationship with mama bear
wills it's an inexpensive online will
here through ramsey solutions
you can go to daveramsey.com and we can
check in the show notes here
with mama beer get a will for crying out
loud give that to your kids for
christmas say hey kids i'm not going to
leave you high and dry
if you have to have a hard conversation
like kyle's gonna have with his sisters
here's a couple of things um
just to think through um first plan your
conversation
don't just show up don't just drop it
like a grenade know what you want to say
and where you want to get
and work backwards from there right if
you show up and you're emotionally
charged and you're gonna have a hard
conversation
it just gets explosive and if you have
hard conversations
and they start with well you then
somebody's instantly gonna get defensive
and now we're off to the races so
acknowledge things are going to be
uncomfortable if you have the
opportunity
set up a time and a place let people
know these things are coming
let them know that hey we need to have a
hard conversation about dad we need to
have a hard conversation about our
relationship
and this is for marriages this is for
kids this is for anybody
right this isn't just for kyle and his
sisters but plan your conversation
the second thing is get in touch with
your motives and your goals for this
hard conversation
kyle said it best he wants his sister's
back
he had that relationship with them that
other people envied that other people
wish they had with their families
and then poof it was gone and it's gone
and i i don't want to talk bad about
your parents but it's bad
it's it's went sideways because
of poor planning of people not taking
care of their business
and leaving their children to deal with
things
and so before you have the talk get in
touch with your motives some of you may
want to have hard conversation to say
our relationship has to change now
some of you have to have hard
conversations about you can no longer
talk to our daughter
like you do it's over now
but get in touch with yourself before
you talk to your family once you spend
time getting in touch with your motives
why are you having the conversation what
are the goals for this conversation
where are we going to end up here and
then the third thing is
um is creating a safe space for this
dialogue
right i've gotten some feedback on
social media folks don't like
that i recommend people have hard
conversations in restaurants they think
that's
a cowards way to do it that people can't
get emotional in a restaurant
i like the neutral third party of it all
that's just me but
also i'm not prone to getting off the
rails emotionally
and some people do and that's okay
whatever it is create a safe space for
that dialogue
right get into a mindset that it's not
about you versus
them it's about us coming together it's
about
us joining forces to move forward with
whatever this is going to look like
whatever this is right
make it clear you care about other
people's feelings their motives their
needs
when people feel quote unquote safe in
your presence you give them permission
to actually speak
to actually be heard right stop
don't put this off get it done right get
it done have the conversation
oh just got this notice if you want to
go through the will
text will to 33789 will
33789 get the guide right on how to do a
will preparation checklist it's
ridiculous to not do it
okay but this isn't a will pitch um this
isn't what this is for
i want you guys to know how to have hard
conversations
go have them and get them done and
here's the other thing we're in
coming off a messy we're not coming off
of nothing we are
flat in the middle of a messy political
season of a messy pandemic
of a messy education mess economic mess
this is the season of hard conversations
plan them know why what are your goals
for these conversations what are your
motives
if your motives are just to hurt people
then shut your mouth just shut up
we have enough of that if your motive is
unity
and safety and coming together and even
if other people have to change
incredible awesome and then number three
create a safe space for the dialogue
kyle thank you so much for the call
brother more on your dad
and then reach out to those sisters in a
written letter so they can hold it and
look at it and say
i want you guys back i miss my sisters
it's awesome thank you so much for the
call